boolay cab podcast special guest 38
Special
we gotta first of all go run up the
interview we about to do the freestyle
but I just want to say salute to you bro
I've been a fan for a minute I've been
watching just your whole
business model
um I feel like a lot of artists have
adopted similar practices
um you've been killing it independently
for a long time man so just salute to
you bro yeah I appreciate that man I
appreciate you having me up here of
course and we try to do it before but we
finally made it happen facts man finally
made it happen I appreciate you coming
into town to do this man hell yeah man I
came up here to [ __ ] with you man seven
shots is out seven shots is out right
now make sure y'all go and get that man
that artwork is crazy yeah I appreciate
that shout out to last bones and shout
out to Jordan Commander man you know
what I mean vinyls drop yet vinyls is on
the way man because like vinyl's got a
little crazy yes there is hey 38 Special
let's get to it man he said he brought a
couple Clips let's go
smoke with you man
it's all good man hey yo seven shots out
right now yup you know what I'm saying
my [ __ ] bootleg cab got me in here
smoking some good ass pre-rolls yes sir
I usually don't [ __ ] repeat
and you know let's go hey God huh hey
y'all for 10 years I've been collecting
gold chains half came from rap rest from
cocaine they shine so bright y'all have
to throw shade y'all worse than a bunk
that ass the whole change now my
granddad can't get past his old ways huh
he made a whole lot of cash but won't
save he said Son you can't take that to
your grave and the die rich is when you
pass from old age huh that's probably
why these young [ __ ] down broke I mean
you way too young to be trying Coke huh
my homie on the run for a gun till they
come he gonna turn his breadcrumbs to a
giant loaf I told y'all I am goat [ __ ]
and if I'm not best I am close [ __ ]
this next ball about the smoke [ __ ]
bust down Carter yeah watches Was Made
For You Broke [ __ ] trust we gonna kill
you [ __ ] and pass but you you rap
[ __ ] take them shits up man give me
another beat too man plain Jane worth
more man bleed out 38 Special let's go
let's go let's go seven shots out right
now no I'm saying huh Rochester New York
let's go oh hey y'all ain't asked for
help one time y'all want lines to front
y'all work I was on the front line
talking about who you gonna find man you
ain't getting far putting ten dollars on
pump nine my dope make fiends on one if
they don't want dimes we serve trades
like the lunch line now calm down I
brought one I'm with your wife we having
a fun time to the sunshine
[ __ ] a gun Crown we all got 50 shots in
our Glock now that's a drum line drug
dealing was a dumb ground I realized I
could make brick money off one rhyme I
tried to help some clown but when you're
deaf and dumb the next step to become
blind you [ __ ] stink with a young mind
the only reason you don't like your life
is cause you want mine in the garage
where the Porsche is put new GT3 come
see how 500 horses look I got an office
with a sawfish cup only hire certain
people I'm real cautious from the losses
took you know when I caught a crook his
wife was pregnant and he didn't get to
see how his daughter look [ __ ] bring me
his head on a hook they blew his head to
Pieces they couldn't bring it so they
brought his foot trust
I appreciate you having me
thank you
seven seven shots right now go get that
[ __ ] let's go go buy some merch 38
Special you already know that was crazy
trust whoa I know you just watched the
crazy freestyle we got another one
coming next week presented to you by LRG
don't forget to use my promo code at
l-r-g.com go to their website it's in
the description below and use the promo
code bootleg you'll save 30 off and they
just drop these look at these basketball
shorts boys these things are crazy you
know what I'm saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you something 30 off right now